what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some pretty big news
about Superman Legacy the new DC
universes Superman the new upcoming
Superman movie that is going to be
written and directed by James Gunn
himself now the last time we talked
about Superman Legacy casting it looked
like DC Studios had narrowed it down to
three main people that they wanted for
Superman himself and also three
actresses that they wanted for Lois Lane
nothing was mentioned about Lex Luthor
however today we do have a report about
Lex Luthor and who DC Studios might have
already chosen to be playing him it also
seems like they might have actually
found who they want to play Superman and
Lois Lane as well so we'll break this
all down in this video and if you want
to keep up to date with DC news be sure
to subscribe to the channel and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items winner
gets to pick one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month only a
handful of days left for this month so
just to catch you up the last report
came from deadline and deadlines stated
that DC was doing the first in-person
test with DC's co-heads Peter saffron
and James Gunn and they were doing these
in-person tests on Father's Day weekend
or the Monday or Tuesday after so that
means basically it took place a week ago
they did their first in-person test with
the actors this means that the actors
finally come in person to essentially
read for the role they've already tested
with them virtually but now they are
meeting with the studio acting in front
of them and deadline said that DC
Studios had narrowed it down for
Superman to three actors Nicholas Holt
David cornswett and Tom Brittany for
Clark Kent and for Lois Lane Emma Mackey
Rachel bronznahan and Phoebe dynavert
and according to an Insider report from
my time to shine hello an Insider who
has a really great track record with
Scoops it looks like DC has found who
they want to play their Superman and
Lois Lane and Lex Luthor in a tweet by
my time to shine hello about an hour ago
she stated looks like we're getting this
for Superman Legacy and she tweeted out
pictures or David Corn sweat and Emma
Mackey so we know that DC Studios was
already eyeing these two for these two
different roles and it looks like my
time to shine hello has heard something
that leads her to believe that these two
are our official Superman and Lois Lane
now as far as Lex Luthor is concerned it
sounds like it's narrowed down to be
between two siblings Alexander Skarsgard
and Bill Skarsgard but in the tweet from
my time to shine hello with Superman and
Lois she also posted a picture of Bill
Skarsgard apparently hinting that Bill
Skarsgard might be our Lex Luthor so it
looks like the main castings for
Superman Legacy could be David Corn
sweat as Superman Clark Kent Emma Mackey
as Lois Lane and Bill Skarsgard as Lex
Luthor I gotta say out of all of the
potential Superman actors that were up
for the role I think David Corn sweat
was the best bet that's just my personal
opinion be sure to let me know what you
think about this casting down below and
I do think Bill Skarsgard would make a
pretty good Lex Luthor especially if you
caught him in the recent John Wick 4
movie he was the main villain I thought
he did an excellent job because I really
hated him and that's the actor's job to
get you to kind of hate the villain and
I definitely think Emma Mackey would
make a great Lois Lane but please let us
know your thoughts about this casting
down below this is not 100 confirmed yet
but like I said it seems like my time to
shine hello has heard that this is the
casting so this might be it if it is let
us know what your thoughts are about it
down below don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell so you can
stay up to date on all the recent DC and
Marvel news and so you can enter our
giveaway and also don't forget to follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf
foreign